- Okay, so Outlander
fans have sent some art.
I feel like people, anytime
something is such a big thing
in pop culture, there's
all these like super fans
that always make all this cool art.
- Right.
- So have you received any of that?
- I've received all kinds
of things from, I dunno,
a duvet with my face all
over it, which is so--
- Now wait, did they think you
were gonna sleep with that?
'Cause like, would you wanna sleep--
- Well, of course!
- Do you sleep with your face?
- I mean absolutely, of course.
Hi me. Goodnight.
Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's awesome.
- [Sam] To little dolls of
us to crocheted pictures.
It's I may say very
creative. Very creative.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
That's so funny, though.
- I should get you a duvet as well.
- Yeah. I'll just snuggle
up real tight with it.
I always think it's funny though.
Sometimes when they do give
you art and it's like your face
and it's like, well, it's flattering,
but like what am I, am I like,
am I supposed to put it
in my house and be like,
so this is my face. Like.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- You know? Like.
- It's like, it's awesome
though, how talented they are.
I can't draw or anything.
Are you good at anything
other artistic thing?
- I'm not really. My
mum's an artist actually.
- [Kelly] Oh yeah?
- So I should be, but no, I'm useless.
- What kind of artist is she?
- She makes paper and--
- [Kelly] What?
- Crafts, like pottery
and stuff like that.
She does all kinds of things yeah.
- That's cool
- [Sam] Sculpture, yeah.
- Okay. I think your mom just trumped you.
She's kind of cool.
- [Sam] Yeah.
- Yeah!
- All I've got is a duvet
with my face on it, yeah.
- And an intimacy coach.
- All right, it's rubbish.
- It's not exciting.